[Music]
recently I dropped a video discussing
the big twist in the crimes of
Grindelwald the huge reveal in the Harry
Potter universe film has a lot of fans
play as to whether it's illegitimate
reveal or if Grindelwald is simply
manipulating characters around him to
help his cause throughout this video
I'll be discussing some of the best fan
theories that I've read in the comments
section on my previous video as well as
giving my full thoughts on the film's
ending there will be heavy spoilers so
if you haven't seen fantastic piece 2
yet and I suggest you turn off now with
that out the way welcome to the channel
where I roon it so you don't have to so
firstly I'll just recap my theory which
is that Grindelwald was lying and that
Creedence is not a Dumbledore this is
backed up by the fact that Abernathy and
Rozier move files from the Lestrange
archives and have potentially modified
them this to me makes the most sense and
Grindelwald is more than capable of
doing so but what about the Phoenix that
appeared to confirm that Grindelwald was
telling the truth
well youtuber Lisbeth Nelson sorry if I
mispronounced your name there she says
there's a theory floating around about
Ariana's obscurus living inside credence
and the more I think about it the more
it makes sense we know you can separate
the obscure ears from its host and in
that case it should be possible for it
to be transferred to someone else it
would explain why both Dumbledore and
Grindelwald was so interested in
credence if poor ariana is living inside
of him it would also explain why
Grindelwald didn't know who he was
looking for if he knew Creedence was a
Dumbledore all along he wouldn't dismiss
him but he did cuz he thought it was
modesty he was looking for
metaphorically speaking referring to
Albus as credence his brother is not
wrong in that case because part of him
is area Dumbledore
also it would explain the Phoenix it's
showing itself for ariana not Creedence
to me this makes a lot of sense as the
Phoenix would have been able to sense
the DNA and go to credence which would
have backed up Grindelwald Sly Milani
Prady Ana sorry if I mispronounced your
name that backs up the theory that
Grindelwald is lying with an even bigger
twist on credence his bloodline she
states that in my opinion credence is
one of Voldemort
systems that's why New Guinea sticks to
Baltimore in the end and maybe that
explains why the guinea fell in love
with credence because he is a parcel
mouth so New Guinea can communicate with
credence when she transforms as a snake
to me this makes a hell of a lot of
sense and I definitely think ties in
well with all of the things we know
about credence so far been right I
definitely got that one right as a
theory about credence being Arianna Sun
which while similar to Lizbeth diverts
down a darker path he says what if
credence was Ariana's son from one of
the men who abused her this would
explain how he could have ended up in
the anti witch orphanage and also
explains his age and why the Phoenix
came to him it may also explain why he
cannot control the obscurus I'm pretty
sure I'm pronouncing obscurus wrong
comment below if I'm reading that wrong
anyway Dylan has one of the best
theories I've ever seen that once again
ties in with Ariana's bloodline he says
this is a crazy theory oh you know
what's going to be good but I think
there's a strange combination of
Ariana's obscure yes and the blood bond
between aalverson grindelwald credence
is birthday of 1901 is certainly an
estimate and Arianna was killed in 1899
so Aldous and Grindelwald are all in
love and they can make the strongest
magical bond possible by combining their
blood
when Albus confronts them a fight starts
and because Albus and Grindelwald cannot
inflict damage on each other it
ricocheted off and decimated Ariana's
body but not the obscuri Asst without
any of Ariana's physical body to latch
on to I think he latched on to and
formed a literal lovechild between Albus
and Grindelwald blood that is why
criminal wall always calls him at my son
Aurelius is the magical ability of
Arianna with the DNA of Dumbledore and
Grindelwald if a magical baby suddenly
appeared from two men there would
certainly be reason to send him on a
ship to America and finally Catherine
Jewell says that I think credence
/ Aurelius is the son of Alice's and her
Nuria and his cousin or the grandson of
her which means his mother drowned that
night and he will stay an orphan at
least till they found out who his father
was
maybe it was also a child out of wedlock
and she had to flee and wanted to start
a new life in America that's my theory
it would make more sense in pulling out
a new brother so Grindelwald
said a half-truth [ __ ] /ur alias is
from a Dumbledore bloodline but not his
brother he just could have said that to
turn him against Albers and to make sure
that he fights him also Albus sends new
out to fight against Grindelwald I guess
we'll see a fight between Aurelius /
Creedence and Newt if you think about a
Grindelwald and Albus are both as
manipulative as hell
I can definitely agree with that last
point and it's nice that audiences can
see how people would side with
Grindelwald there is one last theory
flowing around and that is that
Creedence is in fact a walnut whip
because if there was the thing on the
premiere look never mind so what are
your thoughts on the fan theory so far
do you agree with them or do you have an
even better one comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
make sure you like it and check out my
original ending explain video on the
crimes of Grindelwald this is a channel
for people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]